Oh
I'm like a little Salus he's rocks about
new a crackhead lady and she was like
uh-uh I do whatever you want me to do
what I wanted to do nothing for me tiny
I know here I was like you can't do none
for me yet
luckily this is not happening I'm going
with junior we all come from somewhere
from someone who nurtures us protects us
and teaches us some are better at it
than others
[Music]
he's hilarious and jinglin brothers in
this game I'm happy to be explained he's
[Applause]
[Music]
got a lot of lot of us my dad just this
dick just didn't stop but we all live
close to each other you know different
moms dads we call it a little different
dad type so we would share
everything shoes and everything
everybody share if you live in a
hand-me-down place but except it wasn't
even completely done with like you
shared
that you needed that day so I was so I
had a track meet right and I was like yo
I was running track and my mommy's
always make excuses wild and half
shushybye you were first neo sucks
what's your shoe I was like Arab Derrick
I was faster in my socks but you gotta
have on shoes cuz if people you might
guess start with some cleats and we had
no insurance type right stars like
yo so one day I ran my track shoes and I
did real good but my shoes was all
up cuz my brother's shoes and it
was real up so this girl kill my
shoes like you did so good kid and I was
like like like Olivia's are like yeah I
was fast
and then this kids like 13 14 walked
over here ace nobody knows like it was
people running me near a survivor to
whack ass shoes I was like damn just my
wine a decent winter shoes right
it sounds like y'all I'm determined to
get my own shoes I said I need your
monsters on with my mom I was like mom I
need to have my mom can I have mom cuz
that's how you acts in the black house
you never get it out
because your mama cut you off you want
some shoes don't get some goddamn shoe I
was like mumbling I will but you don't
know how you gonna get them so I said
okay imma get you get some shoes so my
boy said how we gonna get shoes going on
I ain't had no job to make money
I just babysit my little nieces no of
mine you know that's ghetto my nieces
was like close to the same as me you
know but one of my uncle's I babysat for
him he wouldn't ever pay me of money he
always paid me and crack rooster I'm not
making it up he wanted me to hustle see
but I'm gonna give you three rocks go
sell these rocks on my three rocks I'm
like that's $30 my boy like oh you might
be able get 24-week selling my own
little cell is these rocks bought new a
crackhead lady and she was like uh-uh
I do it he want me to do for it I ain't
wanting to do nothing for me I nee had
no hair I was like you can't do nothing
for me yet it hasn't reached his full
potential my boy said what we could do
her name was SC he said what we could do
is we can get SC s he could take us to
Kmart we could just give her a rock he
said cuz my cousin is working security
and he said we could steal whatever we
want to steal and I said man I wanna get
caught stealing I'll say just wait your
mother go to sleep you know she got to
work early anyways but wait your mother
will sleep we just gonna go steal some
stuff I said no so it was myself my boy
Rock and Danny so he said all right we
gonna go steal I said whispers take the
bus let you got some bus money on side
wheel the bus lane will SC gotta take us
I said fine so he paired a rock she like
I want all of them at once I was like
nah we got away cuz
crack here to pull off so we going to
Kayla and I was like where the shoe sex
now we try to act like we just fall to
be in there was like where the shoe
section area we're for some shoes so
daddy cause it was like young for her
you can you can you can go get you some
but just get some shoes but
we didn't tell us so we I get my shoes I
put them on the thing in the
middle so I'm trying to walk out what
a little security thing in the middle of
right but I got a nice little cool wall
it looked like they're not even attached
he's like no he said she
so did he's like now still whatever you
want my boy rock like man we really need
some she saying big show like we
can leave with a microwave out the back
I'm like man nah we can't get a
microwave like let's just get our shoes
get out of here I feel real fast already
right so as we're leaving as we're
leaving security walks up he says one of
y'all stole a snicker swear to God
I'm standing still with the shoes on
you're like when I stole a snicker so
here's like no we didn't know we didn't
like no we didn't waste it all
stink he's cursing twelve-years-old
Karstens give a me start saying so
you Larry buddy we like you can't
kill him I daddy so he take us to the
back now I'm nervous they wake up my mom
is like you got two choice you're going
to jail
or your parents gotta come get you so
Danny like I'm gonna say SC my mom I'm
gonna you can't get the rock outside
time to make her come in some like he's
stuck in there he's like no I'm gonna
come get me but she won't mess but you
know so he calls he calls his mom his
mom comes and get him he's getting
up in there when I tell you she
was beating him I was like beating
through the planer I was like don't call
my mama so I said I'm not gonna call my
mama so I said we'll call my dad but I
ain't talk to my daddy forever I mean I
had to call my dad's sister to get my
dad's new girlfriend number to get my
dad's number
so finally Toni answers what you want me
to call him kill him call him dad in
front his new girlfriend's
that mess up his game
all right Tony assets like what what's
wrong I said come get me I was like this
boots that's one thing that says boots
come give me said wait I said they they
said we were still in the Kmart but dad
ain't still nothing I don't say I'm
still like I'm okay sale why you tell
your mom and I said okay I'm gonna tell
her to come get me but I'm gonna give
her your new numbers like I'm on my way
so I said I'm sitting there right so
just me
it's just when's me and rock sitting
there my dad came in and the worst
roll ever his robe is all
raggedy he got his curls are dried out
and he going on what you do is still in
anyway I work for the city but I don't
know that cuz you don't pay child
support so I grew up in the city I don't
know where you work he's saying stuff
only no I work for the city I work these
hours on my I know none of this so right
now so I'm sitting out looking at I'm
hitting my dad my dad goes let's get out
of hand he walks over to rock and says
come on I said nigga
and rock tried to fit up on right now
you wait on your daddy you'll know right
but I believe what the cool part is I
had two shoes